[Music]
hello everyone hello yohan
rooms and jeff thank you for inviting us
today
welcome to talk about cloud work
today we are on the fourth
episode of five videos which aims
to explain how to develop a
Haitian project  with the services of the
google cloud platform and today we are
going to talk about big willie my name is
jean françois mas crazy i am
a club consultant in the entity
professional services d'organisation
le google cloud and my name is yoann le
case so I'm a technical account
manager based in london
so across the channel exactly so tell
me yoann can you tell us
about big yes what is it yeah
of course
then bis cowries and a
cloud data warehouse but  also a
very powerful analysis platform
so it is mainly used
to analyze large volume data with
very short response times so
as an example I can make a
request on several  urs terabits of
data and having my results in just a
few seconds
is magic exactly so in fact
instead of waiting several hours
before having
beaten results has them almost in real time
can you show us how it
works
yeah of course we will look in
the interface so here we are in
the interface by cros and so on the
left you can navigate within its
different projects and table this is where
can be stored been given for
example we are at  present in the
project are you talking about the cloud at and tools
with a number of
databases present and multiple tables
to create a table just go
to my database and click
on this icon plus i can either create
one  table from a source file
or an empty table that I will fill
later we will select a
table from a source file
there we have several choices a plot
from a local file or gi joe  rise and
we also support bic table and
google cloud storage choose a
file that i have stored in google
storage and select the csv format
from the available options i
fill in the location of my file
is then configure the schema
i can either create it manually  or the
provisioned automatically if ever the
source file is well formatted in an
aliotti context it is sometimes
necessary to focus only
on a certain date or on a
certain period thanks to bykov
you can automatically partition to
table by date whether it is the date of  'a
port or the date of a specific column
of your table this allows you to make
queries for a specific date
a given period or all the
data for example here are all my
partitions available for
e-mail medoc beyond  partitions i can
also create so called
views materialize views allow to
create a virtual table which gives the
p  possibility to filter only on
certain entries or even to make
joins with other tables the data
set that I imported today
include road traffic from
sensors placed on the main
Parisian axes on my generic table
I will have  the measurements of everything but
sensors for almost five years but
I also created a view for the
years 2016 2017 and 2018 they are
identifiable by their green icons
unlike the tables which are
blue now that we have our tables we
will be able to move on  when analyzing the
query syntax is based on sql with two
standard or legacy options
it is a relatively familiar language
for analysts so very easy
to learn for example here is a
query that will extract the axes to
avoid by calculating  the average aunt
between two sensors and filtered by time
and day of the week and therefore the big
winners are the jersey wearer
on Wednesday and Thursday between 18 and 19
hours but also near the
strasbourg saint denis metro station
on Wednesday and Friday again
around 6 and 7 p.m.
as you can see on our
reference architecture aliotti it is
possible to stream and data in
big three
from data flow  or big three good this
allows us to do
real-time analysis whether from
the user interface from noah pays
where even a visualization tool like
data studio
we can therefore imagine a graph that
shows you the measurements of sensors  in
real time on a geographical map
there for example this is a map that
shows the traffic in the streets of
london with the data imported in
real time in big rock nice no
so with regard to the patterns big
yes can be considered as a
hybrid database that will have a
relational schema that you find in
classic sql databases and
some features related to the more
flexible no  sql like lists or
objects it is therefore possible to
import data in csv format but also
jason or avron so then many
people wonder but why is
it so fast
I don't have this type of performance on my
databases and  well quite simply
big three stores the data by column
and not by row there are two
main advantages firstly when you make
a biko query it will ignore the
columns that are not necessary and
therefore reduce the execution time
secondly it allows you to
compress data more
efficiently because some columns have
identical formats, for example, you can
think of postal codes,
telephone numbers or addresses if
you ever need to view
data by cros have
native connectors for most
tools  market visualization data
studio click table looker etc
we also have a jdbc
and odb connector it is available if jam  do you
prefer to use a spreadsheet the
results of its queries can
also be downloaded
and in csv or jackson format so tell
me yoann am I going to have to
deploy and operate hundreds or
thousands of servers to be able to
run all this so well  no so
big krit a totally manager service
so if you need 10 or 2000
servers to perform its request
you don't need to worry about it in the
end you just need to write target
and wait for the result great  so we
take care of everything for me so I have nothing
to do for security so not
totally no so the permissions are
done at the database level and
this will also affect the
underlying tables
so you just have to s  ensure that the
right people have access to the right
data
precisely how do I
supervise monitor all of this then there
is integration with style driver so
stack driver will allow you to log is
actually all the access to the big
rock tables but also logging all the costs
associated with queries and storage
and what identity will
I be using when I go to
feed on data sources
from third party systems so be you  uses
its own identity
from the user interface but you
can also use service accounts
which go programmatically
to retrieve data from a
source file and push them
directly into the workbench and then there we are still
talking about finally giving
quantities  huge astronomical data
how does it manage finally to what i
'm going to have to backup and things
back up a simple answer
storage and unlimited on big wave so
no need to worry about it
very well and then if there's data
that i  use my how it goes
then if ever you do not regret
certain tables for more than 90
days it will automatically switch to
a less expensive storage method  e
until the day you request his
tables again and we start again on a
90-day cycle thank you johan it was very clear
thank you for your explanations for the
demonstrations
do not hesitate from now on
watch the description of the video you
you will find resources there to be
able to deepen what
big willie wanted the next
episode will revolve around an
end-to-end presentation of a
development aliotti body is
also in the resources do
n't forget there is the  translation of a quick lab
in French
on what we tell you next time see you
soon
[Music]
on